this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists now we're supposed
to have kate bauer here today
she couldn't make it kate you look so
pretty today thank you very much
i decided not to shave
i think we're gonna reschedule her we're
here with josh wolfe um
josh i wanted to talk to you about so
much today uh this is a listener driven
show so we've got some questions to dive
into
but i heard you say something
fascinating recently by the way you're a
comedian i am and i'm gonna get into uh
some of the comedy
as well although i'm sure it'll be
apparent throughout um
but i want to talk about something
serious first okay your
your marriage i heard you talk about
your marriage and how
kovid may have saved it in a way this
all the pandemic the quarantine
yeah i saved it yeah may have
illuminated some things you weren't
aware of
yes you know i have been a touring comic
for a long time
um and um let's paint that picture what
does that look like
you're on the road how many days a year
how many weeks a year i would tell you
the last
three years in particular i've been
hitting it pretty hard and i would say
anywhere from
40 to 46 weeks wow wow
and but it seemed
okay if you back it up a little bit what
i've realized more and more the longer
i'm in
hollywood which is one of the reasons
that we're moving
is that no matter how successful you get
you always feel like you need to be on
the wheel
this town keeps you on the wheel oh yeah
it be it
this town combined with social media
because you're constantly looking
at people who have more who are doing
better
that's constantly what you're being
shown you need this is cool
but you shouldn't be satisfied with this
because this is next yeah
and that's right i'm going to rest next
weekend after i get this
and then you get that and you're like oh
if i work a little harder i get this
right and this town really keeps people
on the wheel like that it's how they
keep the machine going yeah it's never
enough it's never enough it's never
enough
right so and as a comic
you know or especially early on we work
for chicken fingers
there there is a different comic
mentality which is
i'm going to take this gig because i
don't know if it's going to be the last
gig i ever get yeah
wow it's just that we get we're like i'm
taking this one
i'll rest next weekend so you know how
long the dry years are
and then you know there comes a point in
time in your life where people like i
don't want to see that [ __ ] old dude
do you know what i mean so in your brain
you're like i have this finite amount of
time
i am going to go as hard as i can
so i was doing all of these weeks and i
would tell my wife you know but we need
the money
for this you know i just need the money
for this and every gig
and those aren't lies by the way and we
can make up these stories 100
it wasn't like i was saying we we don't
need to save money or we don't right
but every next gig became the most
important
do you know what i mean by that like
every next gig was like
i need we do need this one because this
yeah
and we had gotten used to
an abnormal life being normal we had
gotten used to
being apart and living apart so when
quarantine came
i we neither one of us realized that
that was what was happening to our lives
and we talked about all the time about
how much we love each other and we have
this great relationship
and i think we it was just talking
points
and then the first two weeks was like a
honeymoon no
driving thriving that's great and then
after those two weeks it was like hey
when are you gonna leave me the [ __ ]
alone like i'm not used to you being
here
we were you this is both of you saying
this we were used to
so what what she had ended up telling me
was you know when you used to come home
and the kids were young it wasn't
i did not look forward to you coming
home i look forward to seeing you
but we had a flow you upset the apple
cart
every time and then i had to come and
reset that [ __ ]
not that i was coming home and doing
anything bad but i have my energy and
she has hers
and she sets up her house for to have
her flow
when it's just her and the kids which
was a lot of the time
so i would come home and [ __ ] that up
and
um then so my kids are older so we
became empty nesters
and that's when it really became her
life my life
and together when i was home i was back
on the wheel
so it wasn't like i was together in home
and present
i was doing shows i was doing gigs i was
taking meetings and she was having her
life
and um we had just gotten used to that
and so
quarantine made us realize how
unhappy we were wow
be with each other to being
you know what i mean we were i was just
like yeah you know
i shouldn't be upset
with you when you walk in the room and
i'm by myself
drinking coffee and you sit down you're
like how's it going
i shouldn't be upset that you're in my
space
because we're married like i want to be
with you
but i was so used to being by myself it
was the same thing like
she was upsetting my flow that i set for
myself which is i do what i want during
the day
i don't really have anyone else to it's
not that i'm out with hookers and coke
but like
i do what i want during the day because
i'm by myself
and we had to re-learn how to be
together and figure out if we still
liked it
and how did you do that we what was the
process like
okay for me it was
putting down my phone yeah um
you know people tell you all the time
hey you got those social media numbers
got to go up content content content
content content
so that's the new chara the dangles in
front of your face for
us right and so it was that i was like
put that down
be more present cook dinner together
not that we could weren't going to do
our work and our stuff anymore but like
sets
time apart walk the dog together set
time
even if it's just as small as this is
the show we're going to watch together
or hey we're not going to turn on our
phones until 10. or whatever those
things were
to reconnect and really be like do
are we still compatible because at that
point i don't think either one of us
knew if
if that is what was happening i think a
lot of these questions start to come up
when we start to have these problems and
they manifest in different ways
they can manifest in a healthy way where
you start asking each other these
questions like are we still compatible
or they start to manifest in nitpicking
and rage and passive aggressive behavior
uh did you notice any of that yes early
on and i also noticed
in recently and i i can tell you
recently and one of the reasons i'm glad
i turned off my phone is i could feel
myself recently
both of us sliding back down into that
wheel
like the last three weeks and things get
tense in our house
we're a little shorter with each other
we're um we we're
when i see us downstairs in the morning
and i'm drinking a coffee and she's
drinking a tea and i'm in the living
room and she's in the dining room and
we're both on our phones
i'm like oh yeah we're back we're back
into
the being those people and so i
definitely feel a slip sliding back in
every now and then
but the nitpicking and the jumping on
each other
a lot yeah a lot and here's the thing
she is a very vocal person she likes to
talk it out
guess who doesn't you know what i like
to do
let's just be let's just figure it out
as we go
i don't want to talk about it every day
i really don't want to talk i just want
to learn how to do it
yeah but she's like this is how we're
going to learn how to do it right
we're going to learn how to do it by
talking about it right
you kind of need a direction right and
it sounds to me like that that's what
she's
she's saying is we need to identify what
what direction in which we're traveling
uh and you're like i just want to travel
yes but she wants us to be like
hey if we have this schedule like from
here to here this one work this is how
we're going to do this
we're going to do from 10 to 11 no phone
we're going to talk you know we're going
to just look at each other we're going
to take a walk or whatever we're going
to do
and i want to be like hey let's just
wake up in the morning
with this is how we know we're supposed
to do it and she's like yeah but we
don't
do that we don't do that we just slide
into what we know best right which is
work
work work not what we know is best
but what we already know we that's the
thing you slide into the
into comfort yeah the convenience yeah
yeah well you talk about the
the the sort of the treadmill the rat
race or the carrot in front of you
whatever you want want to call it
and um there's a philosopher who calls
it object a
and so like it's this term in philosophy
like as soon as i get whatever my object
a is it can be a new relationship
it can be the the dream home it can be
the career it could be the stand-up gig
it can be x amount of dollars it can be
the marriage
it could be drugs whatever we think it
is it's going to be the thing that
satisfies everything
yeah and of course we always get it and
then we always feel
the object of our desire becomes the
object of our discontent in many ways
it's so fascinating that
especially and i can't speak for other
fields
in this field people are never satisfied
people are never i mean i would
i've always said man why does kevin hart
work so [ __ ] hard
he's got a gazillion what else what else
does the rock need
do you know what i mean like you you
have all of these things
but you're still those two dudes are
still grinding
every day now i think if you ask them
and by the way they're both
incredibly positive people and yeah
right and
and i think live life the right way but
like i say to myself well if i reach
that level
i would take more time off but would i
right
but but do you know what i mean but when
are you ever satisfied i want to
learn how to be satisfied i just haven't
figured it out yeah i haven't figured
out how yeah
to do it you know the sort of the four
truths of buddhism are like
one of them has to do with suffering
right and and and the other one is
desire right like clearly there's
there's a connection between yearning or
craving
it's probably a better word and
suffering
yeah now if you were to give a
charitable explanation to someone like
the rock or kevin hart
i don't know whether this applies to
them or not but but the charitable
explanation because they really enjoy
the journey yes
if so that's great but it very well
could be
that well maybe they're just craving
and it's that whatever the new object a
is if i just make jumanji 3
then i'll be happy right right right and
i think the the truth is that if we're
not contented with
where we are it's going to be difficult
being contented
wherever we end up yeah that's so
interesting
to say i have a friend of mine who moves
from state to state all of the time yeah
basically between two states i should
say okay this state
california and where he grew up okay
but every time he moves he's like now
that and you know what i got to go back
because this is gonna be better there
and i'm like i just don't think you're
happy it doesn't matter where you're
moving dude
you're you're chasing you're thinking
your location means happiness
right we've seen this now no joke
probably
between these two states probably done
eight or nine moves that i
that i know of yeah well i i actually
want to talk to you about moving
um but we're going to do it on the
maximum because you're moving to
nashville yes yeah yeah so maybe we can
we can like psychoanalyze that
as as a couple amateur psychoanalysts i
i but i would like
i mean i would love to know like how
what what is satisfied feel like like
how
do you know what i mean like how you
guys seem
i don't know if content satisfied i
don't know what but how do you
know that i know it seems like a almost
like getting on the wheel to reach
satisfied
yeah but how do you i think it's uh
it's it's when josh brought the buddhist
principle that's where my mind went to
is
like life is suffering so it's not about
not suffering it's about how do you deal
with the suffering
yeah um i feel like minimalism has
helped me get to a point where
uh i'm comfortable with boredom so
like going out of my way so i'm a pretty
big extrovert yeah
huge extrovert and the biggest extrovert
i know when we were
when we were in when we were in missoula
montana i remember
just i didn't know a lot of people just
moved there i didn't know a ton of
people so i was kind of like getting
antsy getting uncomfortable
um and melbourne went to a movie by
himself
and he he ceased to always do that but i
just remember one particular time he
went to a movie by himself i'm like what
a psycho
yeah what kind of psycho goes to a movie
by themselves
but then like but then that raised the
question where i was like why am i
uncomfortable with that yeah
so i started to do things that i felt
uncomfortable with that that were kind
of boring
but getting comfortable with being with
myself essentially
so you know now uh i still want
bigger and better things in the sense
that you know we've got a documentary
coming out we have a book coming out
i want to go on tour with the book i'd
love to go and tour the doc i don't
think we can do that though
but uh but long story short i'm always
looking at the next thing but if it all
like just
stopped right now like it's it's not the
end of the world for me
it's pretty awesome we get to do this
every week it really is awesome but you
but it's part of being satisfied do you
feel like
finding that thing that you do
love like for me stand up doesn't feel
like work
stand up doesn't feel like the wheel
yeah stand up is very satisfying to me i
was talking
so let's talk about this word satisfying
i have something it's actually in our
new book that's coming out next year
it's called uh the satisfaction
continuum
and so like i think the problem is we
can that was my nickname in high school
i think i think some people um confuse
uh the different types of well-being and
usually i think what we're talking about
here is pleasure versus joy
so so pleasure is on one end of that
continuum and there's nothing wrong with
it
but like there's nothing inherently good
about pleasure either like
you can you could have sex meaningful
make love with your wife and it's
amazing you get pleasure out of that
yeah
you could also do heroin and get
pleasure out of that possibly even more
pleasure
right and
and that's going to ruin your life right
and the same is even true with with sex
right like
you you can masturbate and get pleasure
but it's not nearly as meaningful as a
as a shared experience with someone you
love um
and and so i think there's this whole
continuum i wrote these four words down
pleasure happiness contentment and joy
we conflate all of them we use them
interchangeably like oh yeah yeah
it makes me really happy or or yeah
we're really happy
together and it's like well that's not a
noble goal happiness
should always be the byproduct not the
desired result
yeah because happiness at least in in my
view of happiness
is well it's fleeting and so we we try
to achieve it's the thing we're talking
about the object a you'll get it and
you'll feel happy
for an hour of day a week a month
but do you feel like that is
part of like the happiness is part of
the chase of getting
what whatever you say object a is yeah
definitely
and so it's not the object itself
it's almost the chase and the happiness
and the chase
in the chase yeah yeah and and not just
happiness though
it's finding contentment so i think the
healthier version of of all of this is
is contentment where it's it's not as
it's not fleeting
like like happiness is it's being
content with the current situation
nothing wrong with improving upon the
situation in fact growth is really good
responsible growth is there's some
growth that's really bad you know
cancer is a you know tumor is a terrible
kind of growth right
so we can have cancerous growths in our
life as well but then ultimately i think
i think the
the the ultimate um version of this what
the greeks would call eudaimonia we
would just call it joy
basically or maybe even tranquility but
but that usually occurs
by the way i'm going to use eudaimonia
in a sentence
you don't know what that means
[Laughter]
so i think we're really talking about
joy here and that's always shared with
other people it's the
and and huh yeah you can't be joyous on
the desert island by yourself in fact
you could be content you could you could
be there meditating perfectly content
monk in a cave but even if you have a
spark of joy
on that island it's because you've
thought about someone else you thought
about the stand-up set you did that was
really good
right and and the times it's going
really well with stand-up you lose all
clock time
yeah right yeah and we call that flow
state or any of these other things but
like
i just call it being alive like there
are the times where you you you felt
like your best
self you you felt like your most alive
self
and and i think those are the things
that we strive for
in theory but in practice we strive for
the
the pleasure because it's easier yeah
you know it's very interesting i
i hate everything
about being a stand-up except doing the
stand-up
i hate the trout i now i do i didn't
when i was younger but at this point i
don't like to travel
i don't like the hotels we've done it
isn't that weird how it starts out so
exciting yeah we did the same thing when
we were on when we first went on tour
i'm like we're doing it yeah
going across the country and now you're
like what yeah
and we did like 100 cities in here and
now it's like we got to do you know 20
cities in here and i'm like [ __ ] man
yeah
you look at that list you're like man i
don't want to go into that city oh my
god
regina oh you're heading up to vagina
i like it up there
but yeah i'm with you but i
what i know that i can't find anywhere
else
is that hour and a half of freedom on
stage yes
but that that's the cost of that that's
the price of a mission basically right
and so that's why it makes it makes the
20 cities worth it because
when we're there and we're talking to
the people we're doing a live podcast or
a book reading
it's it's the flow state it's it's it's
a lie it's weird i hate to be alive
but if we could just tour all the time
and that's how we you know
did our business i actually would be
okay with that even though i hate
touring it is that
so interaction with people that's yeah
you can't replace it no
and if you think about like my wife
asked me over this
quarantine she's like so what wha what's
the
why did you want to be away from me did
you want
and i was like that not it at all you
know with the for sure the money and the
next gig
but like also a little bit of chasing
that dragon of being on stage
it's the only i feel so
alive on stage i feel so free
and just i almost feel more
myself on stage than i do off stage
i definitely feel more relaxed my
shoulders are never up on stage
and i'll catch myself during the day
walking around i'm like you're by
yourself dude what just
drop your shoulders but on stage
everything is just
slowed down and and so i really
i chased that feeling i wish i could
find it somewhere else
i just don't know where else it is for
me you know
but i mean yeah it'd be great if you
could teleport on to stage
you know every night come on you were
back right that would be amazing
but but i mean i think the the reality
is there is a cost of doing whatever we
do whether it is you know the podcast or
or writing a book
and arguing with a publisher about that
or whatever like
those are the parts that that we like
but it's sort of like it's the
administration of life that allows you
to have the
the focus i mean what we want is to have
more of that focused time and yeah
and less of the nonsense but the
nonsense
it often apes the form of of
productivity you mentioned social media
yeah well and then we can even because
you are influential in a way it's like
well i i can i have an excuse to get on
there and post and scroll and like and
all this
i'm engaging with an audience and it's
like are you really
it's also so ego-driven
it's not a mistake that they call the
people
followers oh right i'm like i have
followers
well okay
hey if that's how you that is like that
word alone
yeah by the way 20 years ago no one had
followers other than like cult leaders
yeah jim jones yeah yeah yeah and that's
crazy so you
now we're all cult leaders but you also
this this social media
and even podcast to a point has given a
lot of us
a false sense of self-importance like oh
i can tell
these are my followers so i'm gonna give
them my opinion
and they're gonna believe that's what
they're gonna take as the gospel truth
which you can if you follow podcasts or
anybody on social media it or
it's dangerous these people follow this
person
they don't know anything about them
except what's on their instagram and
what they're putting out about their
fake life
yeah and their whatever their views they
want to pretend to have or really have
whatever
and these people are taking it like this
is how i should live my life
yeah followers it's dangerous it is
it makes us ryan and i before you got
here we were just talking about how like
this is the mommy and daddy syndrome
it's i either want the government to
take care of me or now
i want an influencer to take care of me
how well to give me the template
and i think ryan and i are really
careful because he and i have radically
different beliefs about
spirituality we have different beliefs
about politics we voted for two
different people in the last election
let me guess which two no no no no i
don't mean which one to get but it is
right yeah well yeah but there were
actually more than two people to vote
for in that last election yeah
that's true there were yeah it should
have been more
right and so i think what what we what
we've
identified here is that we we can be
you know different human beings [ __ ]
where was i going with this i was i was
so
different human being yeah yeah oh we're
careful with our message like we don't
we don't try to proselytize
oh yeah that's it recipe instead of a
template right so like
i i think that there is a um
if you're trying to follow exactly the
template then you want to and you want
to be you know whoever logan paul
or something yeah like good luck you
can't you can't be logan paul
right if you want to be ryan nicodemus
you can't but you can look at his recipe
and say oh i like that ingredient i like
that ingredient
that one's disgusting i don't like that
right yeah and
you can kind of create your own recipe
yeah in a way and i think that's what
we're really careful like ryan said not
to proselytize yeah
should we get any of these questions you
think yeah probably gonna go on forever
yeah i'm happy for it to go on forever
yeah yeah we got a lot to talk about
let's
let's answer at least one question here
all right speaking of saskatchewan yes
we have aaron and regina
[Laughter]
i've completely minimized my life i
accept
my boyfriend i haven't minimized him in
any kind of way
so i guess i should first state that
he's perfect otherwise
because i know you're going to tell me
that i can't change people around me but
i can change
people around me he likes to pile up
dishes
at the sink in the sink all around the
house
and i had an epiphany today that what if
i
just box up my entire kitchen and just
leave him one plate
you know one set of utensils you know
coffee mug
that can be used for juice and coffee
and um take all that stuff with me
when i leave for work next week and just
kind of see how
that holds up so i guess i'm just asking
for some advice
on living with someone who can't seem to
put anything away and just has no plans
to do that but
other than that they are perfect
speaking of passive aggressive behavior
i mean i i aaron i actually respect that
you're trying to do something and yes
you're right so we've got this little
line
it goes up you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you
yeah meaning you can't yeah force
someone to change
yeah but you can surround yourself with
people with similar values etc right
right now here's the thing like you got
to ask yourself this is really
we were talking about cost of admission
earlier but this is her cost of
admission i agree a hundred percent
yeah but you know i makes me laugh when
you get married or you move in with
somebody and then you try to change them
no
hey you bought this ticket this is what
comes with the ticket
yeah there's nobody perfect so you can't
marry somebody or move in with them and
then be like hey
so i'm gonna change this about you no no
no right you knew this was the deal yeah
like this was there are certain things
about my wife about all of our partners
you don't love but i can't that's who
she is
so i gotta take there's nobody perfect
no i can't tinker until i find
perfection
is never gonna happen right no if you
don't if that's the only problem
i think you made out pretty good
yeah they're perfect otherwise yeah that
sounds pretty perfect
like all you gotta do is just dishes
like yeah listen erin wash a dish
well you know what's interesting like
i'm kidding
no i mean you know with like uh mariah
and i my wife and i
uh like she does the dishes and and like
it's it's it's
great like i really appreciate it but
there are some times where she's like
hey look if you got one dish
like just don't leave it in the sink go
ahead and do it so there are certain
things that she asks me that i'm willing
to sacrifice
and when i'm willing to sacrifice stuff
for her she's willing to sacrifice stuff
for me and that's what a relationship is
so the question aaron is like you know
are what are you sacrificing for him
and can you go to him and say hey look
like for this to really work better
like i really love to sacrifice this for
you do you mind doing x
y and z for me and maybe you can get the
conversation started there but yeah i
totally agree like if he was always
piling up dishes you can't just expect
that he's not going to do that um no but
you can't have a conversation yes
you can tell them how important it is
and and not in a way here's the thing we
want we want to avoid three things we
want to
avoid blaming and shaming and i think i
think
passive aggressive action for sure
yeah yeah and instead and also like name
naming like name calling right so that
can be passive aggressive way or that
can just be aggressive right depending
on how you handle it
and so i think that's often the problem
here is
what happens is intellectual we know
this isn't on
par with what we want and so but we
react emotionally
can't believe you you're just going to
leave those dishes in the sink like that
yeah
yeah and it's like well maybe there's a
better way hey
can i talk to you about this look i know
i've got a little bit of ocd
and i don't like having dishes in the
sink would you five words would always
help me would you be willing to yeah
would you be willing to do the dishes
after you we're done eating
dude totally what you're gonna say no i
hate you that's exactly you that's
exactly what mariah she only
had to ask me like one time or say
something like that one time she was
like basically
talking about how she felt disrespected
if i just left like one dish in the sink
and i was like oh i didn't realize i was
making you feel disrespected so that was
but she didn't come in and be like
really what what the heck's your problem
dude yeah like you're a freaking slob
what is it i mean like if she would
approach me that way i probably would
not have
yeah exactly do you know um both beth
and i
had dishpiling tendencies
and so i told her i go hey here's what
we're going to do for a week
paper plates yeah do you like eating on
paper plates
and she in plastic forks and everything
so everything we just picked and threw
away she was like i don't
this makes me feel like a child i'm like
then we gotta we gotta do better yeah
together we gotta do better because i'm
just as bad and if there's a period
where like
you know you're like we both get in
those head spaces where we know
that might pile up in the in that pile
up head space
and she said she's she'll say let's go
paper this week dude together we gotta
do better yeah
so that's how aaron has to approach us
with her partner well that's maybe
so for what she and i have been trying
to do together
it works better if i go hey let's do
this together yeah of course that's
i'll i'll wash them up you dry them off
and that way even if they're my dishes
or even if they're her dishes or
whatever they are there are dishes we
live in the place together
yeah but there are there are things
about like i said there are things about
beth that i just
uh shh i'm not going to say any because
i know she's going to listen to this but
but but they're they're but but that but
i have said to her
i know this is part of who you are yes
so
she was like that bothers you i'm like
yeah but i know this part this was part
of
i knew this about you when we got
married so it's not like i'm gonna marry
you
now change like i can't i felt like that
was a really unfair thing
for me to do if it bothered me so much i
we shouldn't have got married
and that's the most mature stance
because quite often it's the opposite
like
we got married now it's time for you to
change into the person that i
aspired to marry yeah yeah and of course
that doesn't work now i think what
you're saying here and i love this is
it is possible to dislike certain
aspects of someone and still love the
whole person
and i think if we can if we can yeah
yeah if we can make that distinction
like
i'm going to do there's certain things
ryan does i dislike certain things i do
that he dislikes but but i can't even
appreciate those differences between us
man
i think ultimately that's where you want
to get is is being able to respect and
appreciate those differences but
first the first step is tolerating right
yeah you have to you have to get toward
respecting
like californians in general they're
very tolerant remember
when we first came to go about
everyone's so nice here the first time
we were in california
yeah we're in chipotle line and this
lady turned around she's like we are not
nice we are tolerant
i will say that's true for the last
couple months i've really made it an
uh my point when i walk my dog or go
anywhere i
eye contact and say hello to everybody
yeah because everybody's all masked and
it's like so hated now yes that for me
more than ever it's important to show
you i'm not afraid of you dude right so
hello yeah
and that's true because some people
just look at you like what the [ __ ] like
not even a hello back
right they're not used to the friendly
part of it they're more tolerant they're
they're not gonna tell you to [ __ ] off
but they're not going to say hello
i grew up in massachusetts in a small
little town
um in western mass and so
we were all friendly yeah right that was
not even an issue for us but
i think like saying hello to people on
the street
is it's so fascinating how
much people don't expect it they don't
expect any kind of interaction with
somebody they don't know
yeah they're almost jumping yeah like
what do you want yeah like what do you
need something for me
you know in new york i like doing it one
of my favorite games in new york
is to be overly friendly to strangers so
i was in an elevator with this dude it
was just me and him we were in a
high-rise
and we get in the elevator and you know
if it's just you and one of the person
in an elevator there's certain
etiquette rules yeah yeah like if he
stands in the back left
i stand in the back right right i did i
stood
middle shaded over a little to the left
so i was a little too close and i had my
headphones in but not on
because i wanted to hear and as soon as
we both get on he took back left and i
took
center left a little back and i just
heard him go
so we both hit our buttons and he was
like
40 and i was like 21.
and i'm sitting there and i'm just
pretending to sing
my song and i can just hear him just
heavy breathing in the bed just like
all right and my floor open this is all
pre-covered by the way
pre-covered i'll freak over this when i
was still traveling and actually getting
in elevators with people
and um the elevators open up and i hear
him go this is your floor man
and i go i'm on a ride up with you
and he just put his hand over the door
and he goes the [ __ ] you are this is
your vlog
but i like doing that stuff man a friend
julian
julian smith he uh he he likes to make
himself uncomfortable like
it just like stressed stretch his
comfort zone a bit and i think that's
one also one of those keys to
satisfaction yeah so so i i think that
helps you
you know be comfortable in more
scenarios any time he gets on an
elevator he just continues to face the
back
the entire time even if it's a full
elevator so everyone's facing the other
way and he just keeps because i mean you
get on that way
everyone just turns around though right
i love you and he doesn't turn around
he just stand there at 411
i'm definitely i like that's great
feeling uncomfortable i
like making other people feel
uncomfortable
not in a gotcha way i don't like doing
that but i like the shared experience of
i love that feeling i mean this is
really how i live
my life i enjoy you're not watching us
on youtube who sure says i like weird
[ __ ]
i do i like it so much yeah if you ever
start a sentence hey do you want to see
them like just stop right there yes
yeah if i've never seen it before the
answer is i do want to see
yes i want to see that yeah right i'm
going to skip
lottie's question aaron i'm going to
send you a copy of our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life
there's a relationship chapter in there
we talk about
the three different types of
relationships i won't go into detail
right now but if you like our podcast
you'll like
the audiobook version of minimalism live
a meaningful life
or if you want the book book or the
ebook version we'll send you a copy of
those as well
ryan what time is it it is time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
area code 937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts strangely enough
go to both of our phones
we answer as many as we can um but we
answer some on on the podcast as well
josh here's what we try to do during the
lightning round we answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response
okay but not really we
just ramble and ramble clean it up and
post yeah you look real good man
he finds something beautiful he puts it
in the show notes so people can copy and
share
our pithy answers on social media we got
a question from lisha
how will i know when i've found the one
woo yeah man um here i'll give you an
opinion in fact on the maximal i'm going
to read this excerpt from our
forthcoming book about this the it's
called the one
lie because ultimately i think the the
idea of finding the one
i get it there's a lot of romantic
comedies that make me feel like
my wife is the one sure there are other
ones though
yeah if i'm being honest well people who
have been married more than once
right yeah we would tell you that they
thought that first one was the one
yeah and now the second one is the one
and it's interesting too because like
they actually could have been the one
for the for you know for the 10 years
and then i mean [ __ ] changes man people
change
it's like it's yeah so i think i agree
with you the
the one is a lie you have to be open to
that person always maybe being the one
but also open to like
maybe they won't be the one one day you
know there's nothing wrong with
approaching a relationship like that i
feel like first i will say you mentioned
romantic comedy and you give me a
mcconaughey failure to launch
vibe
do i yeah all right all right all right
but i i don't know
about the idea of the one yeah i can
tell you this
when i met my wife ten days
later i called my parents and this never
had never talked about marriage before
and i was like i'm marrying her
there was something about her in
specific
that was just different made me feel
differently
than anybody i had ever met and so
um i don't like i don't know
about that and i don't know if that's
god forbid anything ever happened or we
broke up
if i would ever feel that way about
somebody else i have no idea right i do
know that this
woman was different than any other woman
i had ever met before
and when i met her i don't know if you
know this about me i was a single dad i
was raising three kids
right and they're all grown now they're
all grown um
two of the i had met a woman early on in
my life
who had two kids and we had a kid
together when and when we broke up i
kept all three kids
and so when i met beth um
you know that feeling for the one oddly
enough i had kind of reserved for my
kids
i was like this is where my heart is
gonna be yeah from here on out
we're definitely gonna be talking about
that because uh yeah i i think this idea
of love is like
there are different kinds of love right
but and i had never felt
when she when i met her after a couple
that first night i was like this just
must be because i hadn't
been close to a grown woman a long time
this is why i because i had just been
with
three kids and i had in my brain you
know it's funny in my brain
people would always try to set me up i'm
like hey i'm not going out
i'm at a seven as far as seven to ten
happy mm-hmm
i know what it's like one of these
breakups brings you down to a zero yeah
i'm not willing to go to zero with these
three kids so seven is cool
i'm happy i'm raising these kids they
bring me so much joy there's a part of
my life i'm just gonna
neglect for a while and i was okay with
that because i wasn't
really willing to risk going back down
to that [ __ ] bottom
with the three kids it was just crushing
doing it before
yeah but meeting her right away was like
oh this is a different
yeah this is a different person so like
i agree with you i think ryan and i both
felt that about
our wives as well so but but what i'm
saying with respect to the one in fact
uh dan savage has this great line he
says there is no one so find your
7.9 that rounds up to one yeah yeah
right
and because you even talked about how
like there are certain things or when we
go talk about aaron's question
the dishes well he's not the one he's
maybe he's the the 9.7 though that you
can round up or
the 0.97 you can round up to a one and
and i think unfortunately looking for
the one sets a really bad expectation
because
it presupposes they're going there's
going to be the perfect
relationship and i think when we're
seeking that we're we're just setting
ourselves up for
tumbling down a hill of discontent i
think romantic comedies do a
complete hollywood does a complete
disservice to actual relationships
because you see these two people and
you're like oh i should feel like that
and this relationship well it's not that
one that i saw on tv
yeah i'm still waiting for that feeling
and guess what that feeling
doesn't happen like that here's a here's
the bottom line
i'll tell you right now i love my wife i
don't love her enough to stand out in
the rain and kiss her with my jeans on
you know what i mean like that is a
romantic comedy thing you're not going
to find anybody i like
willing enough to stand out in wet jeans
you know what jeans is the worst feeling
ever
you know what i mean so yeah
so i love you but not wet jeans yeah
oh my god yeah you know what's funny
about those movies is that the
the movie is the story leading up to
that kiss
which is really the beginning of their
relationship yeah it's leading up to
them finally getting together
you don't see the movie about after they
get together and have kids
and have all the other [ __ ] that happens
in life yeah it's exactly yeah i totally
agree man it's it's a bit of a
disservice because that feeling
you might be able to capture that that
you know kissing someone in the rain
feeling but that's that's that's not
gonna last
forever that is a that's a pleasure that
is ephemeral and it's okay to feel that
pleasure
but to expect to feel that pleasure 100
of the time up until the day you die
like that's
that's what it is right is that is that
it's not that that
pleasure might not you might not get it
for a second but to expect your
relationship
day in and day out to be this fairy tale
and not to i think people pull the plug
on relationships
to marriages especially too quickly now
yeah
like as soon as there's one lull yeah
they think well that's the [ __ ] end
of the relationship right
does it but you're gonna have lulls yeah
you just gotta ride them out together
like we've been together since 2001
there have been a lot of ebbs yeah right
but you just have to go this is an app i
think you've got to make sure you're
still compatible though
uh our friend dr christopher ryan uh he
he talks about the three things that are
necessary in a relationship so instead
of looking for the one i'd probably look
for these three things
first off is chemistry and i think
that's what you're talking about when
you when you met your wife's first day
of course there's chemistry right yeah
we often mistake lust for love
um but i think there's chemistry in
other relationships as well non-sexual
relationship like ryan i have a
particular chemistry we even use those
terms right
when we're talking so any relationship
has chemistry any relationship has
love any good relationship at least in
any relationship has compatibility
those three things are required i think
the problem quite often is
that we hold we get into a relationship
because one or maybe even two of those
are working
right it's just the chemistry it's there
we're all over each other all day it's
great
and yeah of course i love where i have
this deep affection for
this person right but then you realize
like oh no we're not compatible and
there could be a thousand
thousand reasons why you're not
compatible like if your wife is like no
i hate kids i never want to see a kid in
my life you'd be like well that's gonna
be kind of a problem for us right those
three people
they can just put a blanket on them have
a packing party with them
tell me what time they go to sleep i'll
be over after that right and so
i think we we have to realize that like
quite often
we're not compatible now there are other
things that happen as well we get into
toxic relationships then
of course you want to abandon that as
soon as you can if someone is behaving
in a toxic way
whether it's verbal abuse or god forbid
violence or something
um let go of that um because that rage
stems from a deep sort of insecurity or
immaturity
as do any of our sort of anger issues i
think they often stem from
this place of of insecurity yeah i think
ultimately though uh alicia you wanna
you wanna realize that you are complete
in an empty room right
and so whoever you bring into your life
they're going to enhance or augment or
amplify your experience of life
they're not going to complete you
they're not the one that completes you
you're already complete yeah i totally
agree uh
so we've had time to prepare for this uh
answer so um
we've got yeah we've got some pithy
stuff ready mine is love from another is
not a substitute for self-love
and i think um people they often
tell themselves if i find the one then
my life is gonna be complete
and it's really what i'm saying the same
thing as josh is you have to be really
comfortable with yourself
and then you can bring someone in to
like amplify your life
but love from someone else is not going
to
uh it's it's not going to be a
substitute for that love that you need
to have for yourself or that acceptance
that you need to have for yourself even
though it seems like a really easy fix
like oh man i got a bad life i really
don't like who i am i need to find
someone who loves me
that'll make me feel good uh sometimes
it actually makes you feel worse
because then you got someone who loves
you and who's treating you well but you
still don't feel like you deserve that
love so then that comes out in other
ways
josh have you ever felt like you've
gotten into a relationship or known
anyone who's gone into a relationship
who didn't really much like themselves
and they thought that it was going to
fix them
in a way oh yeah you know um
one of my
it's um so it's a
okay there's somebody who's very close
to me i'm not gonna you don't say we
won't go your name yeah but
uh it's tim from a friend of a friend
it's it's
heartbreaking for me um because she
is incredibly unhappy with who she is
and has turned to
um alcohol and dudes
to try to fill that hole
yeah and has is willing to
do things that she doesn't like and is
willing to be a person that she doesn't
want to be
in order to keep somebody's love and
it's heartbreaking for me to watch
because and it the the thing that really
makes you beat your head against a wall
which is like how come that person
doesn't see
and it doesn't matter how many times you
say it to him i wish you saw
what we see when you look at yourself in
the mirror
but she doesn't she has zero self-worth
she has
zero feelings that she's lovable or that
she's
worth love and so she's constantly
chasing it from
people and because of that is never
finds it
because at the end of the day she's
always feeling empty yeah you can't fill
a hole with a cup in it or a
cup with a hole in it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i like the other way yeah
hole with a cuff yeah that's great but
but i
i too you know i battle a little bit
with depression
and i can feel it coming and even though
i'm
cognizant of it and i know when i'm in
it
um i'm always looking for other things
or
and so when i'm depressed i smoke more
weed or
whatever it is to fill phil phil so i'm
the reason i see it so much in her and
it's so heartbreaking i feel it for like
maybe a week every it's dark those are
dark deep places
when i talk to her she's like this is
where i am all the time
damn all the time yeah and so it's
really
heartbreaking to know that she's she
feels stuck and i
and there's nothing that i feel like
that anybody from the outside can really
do until she gets
tired of feeling that way i don't know
how to
if she can be you know your instinct is
to rescue or to go help and
so it's a really tough situation for me
and beth
because we're both super close to her
and and uh feel super helpless but
just watch from the outside as that
drain just gets
circled all the time you know yeah i
don't know like
is there any i mean it's i think once
you're in that a place like that like
you have to
you have to stop bringing in external
things to try and fill that hole
so how do you get her to that point like
someone someone is not going to get to
help until they want help
and the help that i would recommend for
someone like that
is you got to surround yourself with
like an awesome community so whether
that's like
a racquetball club yeah or church
whatever it is like find a community
that you that a supportive community
that you can get behind
and go talk to a professional man like
there are i got a i got an
awesome therapist and i'm telling you
having a good therapist
is like one of the best tools that you
can have in life she
lies to her therapist yeah she's got to
be honest first
she lies to her therapist she lies
herself yeah the only therapist that
stuck i finally found out they're stuck
because
the therapist wasn't challenging her
so she was lying to the therapist and
telling
i would talk to the therapist and be
like what's the deal um and she said
well this is what she's saying and
i was like this is not the truth yeah
and you're letting her get away
with that so so there's no honesty
in the safest place possible there's no
honesty
it's been really tough to watch um
because you're constantly
you think somebody else's love is gonna
make you whole
and it's just but because
that person who's chasing that love
always finds unhealthy love
yeah because she's willing to be treated
in whatever manner that person wants to
treat her
as long as he stays there yeah there's a
there's just there's a temporary thing
that she's obviously getting from the
alcohol and from the men
and that's just it it's temporary that's
why she just continues to go after it
but
it makes me think i had a family
relative who
uh they were addicted to heroin had a
few family relatives addicted heroin
um and this this parent of this family
member brought me in and they're like
dude he's off the rails like we just
tell him something to
to help him and i'm looking at him and
he's just like oh what's up
what's up and i'm like there's nothing
to do here like this kid does not want
help
like there is there is no there's
nothing for me to say to this person
like they don't want
help they're gonna i could i could give
them the best tony robbins speech that
they've ever heard right now
like the most motivational speech that
this person has ever heard
but i can see that they don't want the
help so no matter how much help you give
someone if they don't want it like
they're never going to fix themselves
she's got to start being honest with
herself but until she wants to change
like
what are you gonna do you can't force
someone to be honest with you you can't
you can't you can't drag him
or her kicking and screaming to success
right like i'm
i'm going to make you successful i'm
going to make you
whatever it goes back to the whole thing
you can't change the people around you
can't
actually change someone unless they're
trying to change
i don't think people actually hate
change though they hate being changed
we all like good changes right like if
all of a sudden you look in your banking
account there's an extra hundred
thousand dollars in there i love this
kind of change like
is there something you want to tell me
yeah you're the 100th guest
or you get a pair of pants out and
there's like a pocketful of change in
there you're like i love this change
yeah well i mean it's heartbreaking to
watch someone you love
not you know you want to shake change
into them
but you can't you know i've had addicts
in my family and like it's heartbreaking
to watch
but you you do realize like there's
nothing i can do to change
this goes back to that question for the
woman washing the dishes there's nothing
i can do
to change you zero things that i'm going
to
say is going to change who you are yeah
it might change my behavior temporarily
yeah i'm going to feel a resentment
because of it though and and that's
the resentment's obviously never good
for the relationship
all right before we get into our
listener tips and added value segment
today it looks like we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week
yes indeed including why is josh wolf
moving to nashville where are the
minimalists considering moving
what should i do when my values and my
partner's values simply don't align
how do you check in on an introvert
during hard times without overwhelming
that person
how do i find a middle ground with a
partner who is hard
to deal with plus a million more
questions for josh wolfe and the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that
check out our maximal episodes on the
minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast our private
podcast is
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn any income
because we don't believe in
advertisements by the way if you're not
subscribed to our private podcast you're
literally missing
two-thirds of our show so try it out for
three or four weeks
we think you'll get immense value from
it it's worth way more than the two
dollars that we
we charge you it's worth at least 250.
250
a day no i mean actually it's like
that's like
what 25 cents a day or something like
that it's relatively inexpensive but
what you get for it is these really deep
conversations where we let our hair down
we're able to talk about some things in
fact with josh wolfe there's quite a few
things that i
know for a fact we wouldn't talk about
on public because i know he wouldn't be
comfortable talking about some of these
things
in public so if you want to check out
all that it's our private podcast head
on over to theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi this is ansen feller i'm calling from
salt lake city
utah i'm a designer and frequently
helped clients navigate through the
process of creating an intentional home
and in this process i avoided trends at
all costs
if we really look at what trendy design
is
we see that it's designed to encourage
consumerism
companies are motivated to make products
that will eventually go out of style
so i direct clients to architectural and
design history to inform the style of
the home
quality is just as important in function
as it is in design
hi this is tracy from madison wisconsin
and i wanted to share that over the last
maybe six weeks to two months my
relationship with social media has
drastically changed because my intention
with it
has really changed mainly i'm a kidney
donor and i started really speaking up
about it and trying to educate people
and becoming a resource
for people who are curious about it
because there's so few out there
because this happens but almost nobody
talks about it and it's been so
rewarding
and that almost well every week a new
person or even more than one person will
contact me about donation
and it is the most rewarding way i have
used social media
i also talk about finances which is
actually spurred from the budget podcast
by the minimalist
and i have gone like hell bent on paying
off debt not using credit cards and i
now have this ripple effect in my social
network of other people that are doing
the same thing
so it feels good to be intentionally
spreading the good
and sharing the things most people don't
talk about and seeing really positive
results and even
richer and more positive connections
coming back from that all right y'all
thanks again to josh wolfe for joining
us today yeah two places to send you
he's hilarious i think his youtube
channel is a great gateway into his
comedy short clips
he has so many especially if you if you
have kids but even if you don't have
kids it's hilarious
um it's a bond there's bonding within
his humor
in a way that i don't experience with a
whole lot of comedians
and he has some great specials what's
the one that you watched recently father
of the year
yeah father of the year so you can check
that out but also his youtube channel
just these short three five ten minute
clips of him on
stage but also we'll put a link to that
in the show notes let's put a link to
his
facebook fan page as well because twice
a week he does two
live shows on facebook hundreds of
thousands of people watch these things
one is called controlled chaos the other
is called a high
live we'll talk to him about both of
those on the maximal episode but
check those out his facebook fan page
it's really the place where he's able to
get personal
and be himself unencumbered
uh we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well for added value this week
ryan
i don't know if you've heard it yet uh
sufjan stephen's new album just came out
it's called the ascension
no you know sufjan steve yeah yeah yeah
i like sufjan i like
i like some of his albums and he's so
experimental sometimes like
he made a classical album a few years
ago remember there was a time where he
was experimenting he was going to do
a album titled after every state so he
put out an album called michigan one
called illinois
i think illinois might have been like
his sort of breakthrough independent
album
but um his album that came out last
decade i think it was
what year was that 2011 2014
2013 it's called carrion lowell it's one
of my favorite albums of the decade
i don't think i've listened to that one
it's super singer songwritery but this
new album it's called ascension
and it's kind of ethereal i don't even
know how to describe it it's ethereal
it's like if singer songwriter met
siguros
i was just thinking like when i think
ethereal cigarosa is the first person
that comes to mind
yeah the first band that comes to mind
well yeah the title of it's ascension
and it feels like i'm ascending into
something when i'm listening to it
and so i would definitely recommend it
i'm really getting value from it
my favorite favorite song from there is
called video game
and so um i would encourage you check it
out but the the whole album
is out there now it's called ascension
and it's definitely worth
a listen all right real quick for right
here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist well i think it's
your life too
because a new month is right around the
corner in just a couple days
we're going to have a brand new month
and that means it's time for a new 30
day minimalism game
the minimalists.com game to figure out
what the heck is the minimalism game
real quick
basically you uh you partner up with
someone a friend family member co-worker
beginning of the month each get rid of
one item on the first day
two items on the second day three items
on the third day whoever goes the
longest wins if you both make it at the
end of the month you've both won because
it's about 500 items
which is a really good start when you're
decluttering the reason you want to head
on over to the minimalists.com
game though there's a free calendar you
can download also instructions
for the game as well the game is
completely free to play the calendar is
free to download and it tracks how many
items you're getting
rid of each day i would encourage you to
find a friend or family member and let
go
together it makes decluttering a little
bit more fun the 30-day
minimalism game you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo it's a podcast
at theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple
sunday emails whenever we send those and
if you leave here today with just one
message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it